Mussolini has revolutionized a lot of
industries today it can help us
recognize objects prank scenes even
understand what you are seeing but it is
still is early stage and faces a lot of
challenges here at all is the three
major challenges initially nowadays from
research to industry and tell you what
it's our current solution to each of
them the first one is lack of training
data data is at the core of any
Michelini projects however it is really
very hard and expensive to obtain
labeled data how to train a model with a
large amount of data is a very hot topic
today transfer learning is one of the
methods to solve this problem it enables
the model to utilize knowledge from
previous learned tasks and applied them
to the new related one for example in
the image classification task very few
people will train an entire
convolutional neural network from
scratch which surely needs millions of
labelled images instead it is common to
use the pre trained models and find you
need them on the target of the domain
self supervise the representation
learning is another way to solve the
lack of data problems it opens up a huge
opportunities for better utilizing large
amount of unlabeled data here is a very
famous example in language modeling if
there is a sentence but there are some
missing word innate
how can you fill in those missing word
well the idea is to predict the missing
words by learning from the past and
future knowledge the representation of
the language has also learned during
this process google have used this
technique to understand searches better
than ever before which brings one of the
biggest leaps forward in the history of
search the second challenge is that
there are usually some discrepancies
between your training data and
production data sometimes the model
works well in your prototyping
environment but feels too generalized in
real-world cases let's see a few
examples here the model may works well
in one country but viewed in another due
to geographical
the malama working winter but fear in
summer due to three snow differences the
monami works well on mobile but field on
desktop due to user behavior differences
in different platforms so when you are
developing your model you need to be
very careful when you collect your
training data to make it as close to
your target academy as possible and keep
updating your model once it is updated
the last but not the least challenge is
about model scale abilities it is a big
issue for the lot of project industry as
a Michelini engineer you need to make
sure that the model can run fast enough
and the molasses is small enough which
is surely a big challenge for a lot of
tasks one of the possible solution is to
use post to training quantization it is
a conversion technique that can reduce
model sets at the same time it can also
improve CPU and hardware accelerated
latency with little aggregation Amahl
accuracy thanks for watching don't
forget to rain the notification bell and
the subscribers